madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
manifestation pour l'emploi à paris à
l'initiative du parti communiste la
mobilisation rendez vous plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes du
vert et du rouge dans les rues contre
les licenciements mais pas contre le
gouvernement
la région de los angeles touchée par un
tremblement de terre de 7 sur l'échelle
de richter pas de victimes ni de gros
dégâts l'épicentre était à 170 km un
train déraille et plus de peur que de
mal
coupe du monde de rugby décidément le
quinze de france pourrait mieux faire
même s'il obtient sa qualification en
quarts de finale où dernières minutes du
match
expédition poule sud lawrence de
laferrière se prépare à parcourir en
solitaire 3000 km à pied les pieds dans
la banquise sur le soulman l'exploit et
puis les caricatures de daumier jusqu'à
nos jours exposition à l'isle adam avec
pour thème la justice le regard de
plantu le dessinateur du monde qui a
visité cette manifestation commençons ce
journal avec cette manifestation test
pour le parti communiste robert hue
avait mis la barre très haut il
attendait 50 mille personnes pour
défendre l'emploi dans les rues de la
capitale se serait alors l'événement
l'élan social de la rentrée
on s'attardera donc sur les chiffres
pour savoir si oui ou non la
mobilisation était au rendez vous comme
d'habitude c'est le grand écart entre
les estimations des organisateurs et
ceux de la police du simple au double
entre 32000 les soixante dix mille
manifestants sous le soleil et sous des
bannières très différentes
robert hue lui crie victoire j'avais un
berg et millet lançant leur aida32 mille
manifestants pour la police le double
selon les organisateurs la vérité sans
doute entre ces deux chiffres
l'homme du jour est satisfait
la manifestation contre le chômage a
donc mobilisé et elle a surtout réuni
une affiche inédite une tête de cortège
que l'on n'avait encore jamais le parti
communiste le mouvement des citoyens
les verts et extrême gauche sur des mots
d'ordre commun pour que les actionnaires
fassent des profits de l'ordre de 15%
on saccage des vies on ruine les régions
au caire dans ce pays parce qu'on dit ça
suffit
et je crois que là pouvaient nous
prendre un parent quelles que soient nos
opinions par ailleurs on est tous
d'accord là-dessus il n'y a pas de
paradoxe il ya complémentarité
car il faut toujours lié l'action
populaire et l'action gouvernementale
c'était pourtant là toute l'ambiguïté de
cette manifestation
officiellement pas question de laisser
passer des slogans anti-gouvernementaux
le patronat et les marchés financiers
était la seule cible afficher les au fil
du cortège certains refrains était
parfois différents que pensent les
militants de l'action du gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'était un peu la question
piège avec des réponses variable je suis
cadre à la sncf
notre ministre nous a dit aidez moi si
vous voulez qu'on avance donc je suis
dans la rue pour aider mon ministre à
faire avancer les choses
rien n'était décidément simple dans
cette manifestation à l'image de bernard
thibault secrétaire général de la cgt
mais simplement présent at il dit à
titre personnel les ambiguïtés selon
robert hue il n'y en avait aucune
en tout cas pour lui on peut être dans
la rue et soutenir le gouvernement
contraire en tout cas je suis bien sur
mes deux pieds un pied dans les
institutions de la république parce que
c'est nécessaire pour construire et un
pied dans ce mouvement populaire
essentiels sans lequel il n'y a pas de
succès de la gauche plurielle
robert hue semble avoir gagné son pari
la mobilisation et des forts
qu'aujourd'hui et surtout elle n'a pas
dégénéré en manifestation
antigouvernementale
lionel jospin entendent a sans doute le
message la gauche plurielle existe et
elle veut se faire entendre
les ajustements de la loi sur les 35
heures ont déjà dans ce sens et puis les
réactions politiques et à droite de
françois fillon l'un des candidats à la
présidence du rpr parle d'une
escroquerie intellectuelle et politique
ajoutant que le parti communiste et les
verts qui sont au gouvernement tente de
se créer une virginité politique qui ne
trompe personne fin de citation aux
etats unis la région de los angeles a
été secoué en pleine nuit par un violent
séisme de 7 sur l'échelle de richter
l'épicentre du tremblement de terre se
situait à quelques 200 kilomètres de la
ville fort heureusement pas de victimes
ni de gros dégâts
plus de peur que de mal pour les
passagers de ce train qui a déraillé en
plein désert par chance l'épicentre se
situe en plein désert un désert que
traverser ce train
par chance il n'y a pas eu de victimes à
2h46 heure locale ce matin la terre a
donc tremblé c'était à plus de 160 km à
l'est de los angeles
et pourtant malgré la distance les
habitants de la grande ville en ont
largement ressenti les effets comment
est ce que vous avez ressenti le
tremblement terre cette nuit mais au
départ c'est simplement la maison tu
trembles moi j'ai senti la fenêtre au
dessus de moi qui ici prend blais donc
je les tenues et puis tout d'un coup on
entend loulou grondement du tremblement
de terre qui est vraiment énorme
donc on se lève on regarde par la
fenêtre et là on voit le la maison
bull on voit les a pris bou les poteaux
télégraphiques qui bouge on se recouche
et une deuxième secousse qu'un peu moins
fortes et aussi j'espère qu'elle n'aura
pas une troisième est un peu là qu'on a
peur c'est surtout après qu'on a peur 7
degrés sur l'échelle ouverte de richter
c'est le plus fort tremblement de terre
que la californie ait connu ces cinq
dernières années
cette fois la faille incriminé est
proche de celle de san andreas
à cet endroit l'amérique et le pacifique
s'affrontent dans un mouvement qui les
pousse du nord au sud la secousse
d'aujourd'hui même si elle ne devrait
pas être suivie de répliques de grande
ampleur a relancé dans la région la peur
du grand tremblement de terre le big one
comme on l'appelle ici celui dont tout
le monde sait qu'il aura lieu un jour
sans pour autant savoir quand vous états
unis toujours le passage de l'ouragan
irène qui a frappé la floride faisant
cinq morts des pluies torrentielles ont
provoqué de nombreux dégâts
alors que la caroline du nord s'apprête
à être touchée à son tour jacques
cardoze se déchaîne
c'est toute la floride qui s'inquiètent
chaque année à pareille époque le dieu
du vent lance un même défi aux quelques
400 mille habitants de miami et west
palm beach
les eaux recouvrent les routes les
parkings se transforme en lac mais
chacun ici semble savoir comment se
protéger des effets de l'ouragan
nous avons eu beaucoup d'eau qui attend
détruit il a donc fallu pomper toute la
nuit
malgré tous ses efforts le bilan est
dévastateur en floride quatre personnes
ont trouvé la mort électrocuté des
câbles électriques ayant chuté
auparavant
l'ouragan irène avait déjà tué sur son
passage aux bahamas et à cuba ou le
dernier bilan fait état de quatre morts
et 200 maisons détruites
on ne compte plus les champs et les
plantations dévastées à west palm beach
les véliplanchistes ne redoute pas la
violence des vents 120 130 km irene n'a
qu'à bien se tenir les journalistes se
cramponnent à leur micro et le fatalisme
semble atteindre la population
je suis déjà passé au travers quelques
fois après toutes ces années on a
vraiment de la chance mais j'espère que
ça va durer
les aéroports de la région ont été
momentanément coupées
le président bill clinton a décrété
l'état d'urgence dans 28 comtés de
l'état de floride
les météorologues s'attendent à voir
irène débarqué en caroline du nord
dimanche soir au lendemain du prix nobel
de la paix décerné à médecins sans
frontières les hommages se multiplient
notamment celui de bill clinton qui
considère que msf méritait amplement
cette récompense sur le terrain depuis
28 ans maintenant cette organisation non
gouvernementale vient au secours des
victimes un peu partout dans le monde
intervenant dans tous les conflits qui
font ces médecins volontaires capables
de répondre en quelques heures aux
demandes de leurs organisations
portrait de cet homme médecin
généraliste il l'a en commun avec tous
ceux qui travaillent à médecins sans
frontières
la passion et le dévouement le courage
aussi puisqu'il a travaillé aussi bien
en macédoine qu'au kurdistan
sébastien leguay yves janka retour d'un
séjour parisien des plus marquants hier
philippe chazerand était venu assister
un colloque sur la politique du
médicament dans les pays pauvres
quand il est arrivé au siège de médecins
sans frontières ce médecin du jura n'a
pas compris pourquoi l'on criait et l'on
s'embrasser pour partager sa joie avec
ses collègues il était au bon endroit au
bon moment
vaches à la fête hier soir
anti dit comité je pense qu'on a encore
bien refaire les trois quarts du monde
entre entre minuit et 4 heures du matin
garée depuis bientôt dix ans philippe
chazerand répondent aux appels urgents
de son organisation il fit dans un camp
de réfugiés rwandais en tanzanie pour
mettre sur pied une structure de soins
15 missions au total aux prises avec une
épidémie de choléra au sénégal dans les
camps de la cedh one en arménie au
kurdistan ou encore à djibouti la
tanzanie en 1994
c'est le souvenir d'une angoisse qu il a
su transformer en énergie
on est médecin avec un stéthoscope et on
se dit on va pas y arriver
trois cent mille personnes c'est
grenoble qu'on dépasse dans la campagne
est arrivée en pleine brousse
tanzanienne avec trois cent mille
personnes c'est on sait pas faire on a
l'impression de pas savoir faire et je
crois que dans ce cas là on est positif
on arrive à redonner un petit peu de
dignité humaine à ces personnes quand va
aider sa femme marie odile également
médecin et complice de son engagement
quand philippe doit partir dans leurs
ailes le remplace au cabinet médical
le prix nobel est une récompense qui
vaut aussi pour elle aujourd'hui c'est
une grande joie quelquefois signes
d'inquiétude mais on peut pas toujours
il dans l'inquiétude 700 faut aller de
l'avant et quand quand il n'est pas là
c'est sûr qu'au moment où il s'en va
je suis un peu inquiète et une fois
qu'il y ai je fait confiance que je me
dis que ça se passera bien
les médecins du centre médical où ils
travaillent sont tous engagés dans des
activités associatives
c'est grâce à cette souplesse que ce
généraliste organise sa double vie en
fait j'ai trouvé ma place je sais que je
dois travailler ici et mon boulot a
appris que plus de valeur je me sens un
peu plus à l'écouté des gens au
quotidien médecin de campagne et
médecins baroudeur entre le jura et les
pays lointains
philippe chazerand est convaincu d'avoir
donné un sens à son métier
à paris de mahé avant une ouverture à
l'assemblée nationale des débats sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
la grogne des médecins et de différentes
professions de santé qui ont appelé à
manifester dans la capitale contre les
mesures budgétaires alors ils disent se
mobiliser pour sauver le système de
protection sociale et la qualité des
soins
parmi les mesures déjà envisagé
largement contesté le médecin référent
un terme un peu barbare
voici ce qu ils recoupent et voici dans
quelles conditions nous aurons à passer
par ce médecin référent explications
jean bernard schmidt jean louis goût
serre pour le docteur en dessous cette
patiente est un peu particulière elle a
choisi de signer avec lui un contrat de
fidélité
c'est ce que l'on appelle le médecin
référent en échange de cet engagement
elle ne paye que le quart de la
consultation
le reste est directement versée aux
médecins par la sécurité sociale
vous êtes protégé au bout de combien de
temps qu'elle joue 15,6 à simplifier
tout jeu au point de vue remboursement
point de vue tout avait un point de vue
me relation visas avec la sécurité
sociale gestion plus facile mais aussi
suivi médical les patients abonnés sont
moins tentés d'aller voir plusieurs
médecins pour un même mal une source
d'économies selon l'assurance maladie
contre 48 heures que ça permettra de
prendre plus précocement les problèmes
les malades viendront sans nouvelles van
hool lorsque des signes des buts et pas
lorsqu'ils auront déjà été totalement
submergé par la maladie ça permettra
d'adresser aux bons spécialistes au bon
moment et de gérer et de coordonner les
soins qui seront données chez les uns et
les autres
seulement voilà le docteur un chou fait
aujourd'hui figure d'exception seuls 7 %
des généralistes ont choisi d'être
référent et 3 % des assurés sociaux ont
décidé de s'abonner de peur bien souvent
de perdre leur liberté
josé clavéro lui aussi est médecin
il a beau examiner de près l'idée de
malades abonnés
il n'y voit qu'une tentative de contrôle
des médecins et des patients par la
sécurité sociale
moi je ne crois pas qu'on fixe un malade
comme ça parce que nous sommes dans un
pays de droit et de liberté et que
deuxièmement il est bien évident que les
patients qui font ce que l'on appelle du
nomadisme médical ne vont pas adhérer à
ce système là donc soit c'est un système
si on veut vraiment gérer ces
patients-là qui devient obligatoire et
là on perd notre médecine française qui
est quand même l'une des meilleures au
monde et c'est pour défendre cette
médecine selon lui en danger que josé
clavéro ira manifester demain aux côtés
d'autres professionnels de la santé avec
un même mot d'ordre non au rationnement
des soins
les députés ont achevé la nuit dernière
l'examen en première lecture du deuxième
projet de loi sur les 35 heures il sera
voté mardi prochain
en dernière minute le gouvernement avait
en direction du parti communiste a porté
quelques aménagements le parti
communiste qui votera donc le texte de
martine aubry rappelle de son contenu
définitif avec jean-paul chapelle la
durée légale du travail passera à 35
heures par semaine le 1er janvier 2000
pour les entreprises de plus de 20
salariés et le 1er janvier 2002 pour les
plus petites entreprises
l'horaire est désormais un élément du
contrat de travail qui ne peut être
modifié par l'employeur sans l'accord du
salarié en passant aux 35 heures les
entreprises reçoivent une aide de l'état
des allègements de charges mais avec une
condition le nombre d'emplois créés ou
sauvés par les 35 heures doit être
inscrit et vérifier le temps de travail
effectif comprend désormais la pause
casse croûte et le temps d'habillage et
de déshabillage quand une tenue spéciale
est obligatoire pour les cadres la durée
de travail se comptera en jour avec un
maximum de 210 7 par an soit 16 jours de
repos supplémentaires dans l'année pour
les smicards les 35 heures seront payées
même dans les entreprises nouvellement
créées grâce à un complément de salaire
enfin le texte conserve le fameux
amendement michelin qui stipule qu'un
plan social ne peut être lancé sans
avoir d'abord engager des négociations
sur les 35 heures enfin l'an dernier
jour du sommet des cases lionel jospin
en a profité pour revenir sur la
décision de maintenir l'embargo sur le
boeuf britannique justifiant une
nouvelle fois la position de là
france par ailleurs au menu de ce samedi
le projet d'anne espace juridique
européen concernant à l'immigration la
lutte contre l'argent sale et la drogue
il ne s'agit pour l'instant que de
déclarations d'intention qui serviront
de fondement à une politique commune
christian mary mono un conseil européen
consacré exclusivement à la justice à
l'immigration et à la criminalité était
un pari audacieux la présidence
finlandaise en proposer quelques lignes
directrices et un calendrier s'agit
d'améliorer la coopération entre les
polices et les magistrats d'harmoniser
les décisions de justice en matière
familiale et commercial de coordonner la
maîtrise de l'immigration clandestine
est de renforcer la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée
le crime organisé la drogue l'argent
sale ignore évidemment les frontières
l'europe doit les combattre
en agissant dans toutes les enceintes
internationales en faveur d'un
renforcement important des moyens légaux
d'une lutte efficace contre ce fléau de
notre temps pour le britannique à
perturber quelque peu la sérénité des
débats confiance les britanniques ne
comprennent pas le refus français j'ai
levé l'embargo
nous avons pris notre décision sur la
base de fondement exclusivement
scientifiques et médicaux nous avons mis
en place une agence de sécurité
sanitaire des aliments parce que il y a
dans notre pays et je pense aussi
d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays en europe
l'europe de la part des consommateurs
une exigence croissante de sécurité de
certitude en ce qui concerne la qualité
et même la sûreté sanitaire des aliments
malgré ces difficultés l'europe va plus
loin et voit plus grand
les cases son accord pour accueillir 12
payés supplémentaires
ce grand défi sera à l'étude au prochain
sommet d'helsinki en décembre prochain
jean pierre chevènement et et à toulouse
cette fin de semaine pour lancer une
nouvelle brigade baptisé labrecque
il en existe pour l'instant cinq en
france leur mission le renseignement la
surveillance et les arrestations lors de
coups de filet dans les affaires de
banditisme
cette brigade régionale est rattachée au
srpj
l'exemple à strasbourg où elle
fonctionne depuis cinq ans agnès garder
jean francois monier ils se trouvent ou
actuellement neudorf
cet homme dont on ne verra jamais le
visage est un policier de labrecque
une brigade spéciale de répression du
banditisme 18 policiers qui travaillent
sur des dossier au long cours trafic
recel ou proxénétisme
ce soir là ils planquent aux abords de
leur cible un hôtel ou deux filles
seront récupérés par leur proxénète
après deux heures de surveillance où
s'accélère
le proxénète et prise en filature il ne
sait pas qu'il est suivi
et lorsqu'ils déposent les fils ou le
trottoir il ne s'est pas non plus qu'il
est observé
le lendemain six heures du matin
l'interpellation met fin à quinze jours
de filature
ils ont tous les deux 20 ans lui est
français d'origine turque évite à
strasbourg elle et cheikh prostituées
depuis un an
l'arrestation n'a duré que quelques
minutes
la mission de la brèque s'arrête là elle
ne procédera pas aux auditions d'autres
policiers vont prendre le relais
il se trouve que tu apparais en fait
comme déposant régulièrement cette fille
là donc on s'interroge de savoir quel
est ton ta motivation c'est ici dans le
quartier de hautepierre que le proxénète
interpellé a grandi voitures brûlées
affrontements avec la police
la cité tristement connue du délit
mineur au banditisme il n'y a qu'un pas
que certains jeunes ont franchi sans
état d'âme depuis un an
on s'intéresse à ses quartiers à ces
jeunes qui ne sont plus les flambeurs de
voitures mais qu'ils sont
ceux qui utilisent le quartier pour
développer des activités délictuelles de
toute nature ce soit dans les ports en
matière de stupéfiants en matière de vol
en matière de recel et ces gens là donc
profitent pendant que la police s'occupe
à éteindre des feux de voitures se
développe en activité l'image est cru la
réalité sordide ses filles se vendent
pour 200 francs et tous les soirs elle
recommence pense qu'on peut pas faire
assez fier et sûr pour moi retirer les
crapules qui met la main dessus je veux
dire c'est pas grand chose enfin épices
et les voyous mon problème c'est les
voyous quoi et le constat de ces
policiers dur des voyous de plus en plus
jeunes venus des quartiers difficiles
des jeunes femmes qui fait leur pays et
la misère
les premiers exploite les seconds une
nouvelle forme de délinquance est en
train d'apparaître en tchétchénie les
combats se poursuivent et s'intensifient
les troupes russes seraient entrés dans
la seconde phase de leur offensive
dix personnes ont été tués lors de
bombardements aujourd'hui plusieurs
dizaines d'autres seraient de laisser
les victimes d'après les responsables
tchétchènes seraient des femmes et des
enfants
moscou pour sa part affirmé n'avoir
perdu que peu de combattants et
encerclent le petit à petit la capitale
de grosses inexcusable dans la capitale
russe comme ailleurs dans le pays cette
guerre en tchétchénie rallume les plus
vives inquiétudes au sein de la
population et notamment de ces mères de
soldats russes qui au moment du conflit
en afghanistan s'étaient regroupés en
association pour avoir des nouvelles de
leur fils envoyé offrant une association
de nouveau très active comme en témoigne
ce reportage de gilles rabin et france
brille c'est maintenant le foot locaux
qui l'ont seul l alerte à 1h ou 2h du
matin ce qui avait fait un an de service
parlons six mois de service ou plus il
était bon pour partir aux franges
on leur a demandé de signer un papier
une sorte de contrat leur a promis mille
dollars par mois le matin ils étaient
tous partis
pour échapper à ce recrutement forcé il
a déserté avec l'aide de sa mère
c'est à nous de sauver nos fils personne
ne nous aidera personnes elle est là bas
récupérez votre fils je les sentais le
de la ba balle au pied même la nuit
oui sortez le de là pour garder leur
fils vivent les mères de soldats sont
prêts à tout même s'il le faut aller
jusqu en tchétchénie je peux aller
là-bas récupérer mon fils mais comment
je dois faire à vous de voir mais
surtout dès que vous l'avez ne le
laissez pas la maison à menez loïc c'est
bon je pars dès ce soir
depuis le début de la guerre en
tchétchénie
l'armée russe violent délibérément la
loi qui interdit d'envoyer de jeunes
recrues au combat avec bien sûr la
complicité au moins passive des tuyaux
des institutions du pays
alors c'est une véritable guerre que les
mères de soldats livre à l'armée et le
petit bureau de leur association est
sans doute aujourd'hui la seule vraie
république démocratique de russie notre
président lui-même et le premier ne pas
respecter les lois qui signe que pouvez
vous exigez des citoyens ordinaires en
russie plus qu'ailleurs le soldat est un
citoyen sans droits on en voit se faire
tuer dans une guerre qui n'ose pas dire
son nom ni avoué son but he 4000 jeunes
recrues au moins avaient été tués près
de vingt mille autres blessés ou mutilés
lors de la première guerre de
tchétchénie
mais aucun bilan officiel n'a jamais été
publié personne ne lui a demandé son
avis on n'essaie même plus et laisse ça
fait quatre mois sans nouvelles elle
pressent déjà le verdict de ces quatre
mois de silence
son petit fils a été tué ou enlevées
comme otages ou comme esclaves
les talibans qui sont au pouvoir en
afghanistan rejeté aujourd'hui la
demande d'extradition des nations unies
il refuse de livrer ben laden ce
milliardaire islamistes qui seraient à
l'origine de deux attentats contre les
ambassades américaines à nairobi et à
dar el salam en
98 l'antarctique à pied le pari fou de
cette jeune française qu'il y a deux ans
avait déjà atteint le pôle sud en
solitaire
d'ici quinze jours laurence de la
ferrière entreprendra une nouvelle
aventure en traversant la seconde moitié
de l'antarctique soit quelques 3000 km
de marche sur la glace avec pour seul
écho le bruit de ses pas virginie fiche
et olivier jacquelin le rencontrer à
quelques jours du grand départ
bientôt trois ans que laurence de la
serrière à ses connaissances avec le
pôle sud
je me suis senti libre je me suis sentie
force j'ai trouvé ça beau j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement riche et je lui envie de
revivre une nouvelle fois revivre
l'aventuré et surtout poursuivre la
route cette fois elle partira du pôle et
rejoindra la base de dumont d'urville au
sud-est de l'antarctique une échappée en
solitaire de plus de 3000 km à travers
ce désert glacé
nous allons entrer dans l'antre en
attendant le chalet familial a pris des
allures de camp retranché bien un petit
peu difficile actuellement de pouvoir se
reposer dans cette chambre
l'aventurière prépare ces derniers
bagages avec la décontraction d'une
vacancière
mais la désinvolture n'est qu'apparente
chaque objet a été soigneusement pesé le
moindre drame a son importance
chaque détail du matériel a été vérifiée
adapter la base sur la glace il sera
trop tard pour faire confiance au hasard
il faut être à tout moment capable de
trouver une solution
là où on arrive aux limites du
fonctionnement d'un matériel parce que
les conditions comme moi 50 comme celle
que je vais trouver en étant seul à
pouvoir faire face à chaque chose
rendent tous extrêmement critique
en 15 ans d'expéditions entre himalaya
et articles l'extrême est devenu le
compagnon de route de sept alpinistes si
sûre d'elle un mètre soixante façonné à
la force du piolet un caractère
déterminé qui sait ce qui l'attend sont
jamais le redoute et laurence de la
ferrière a appris à apprivoiser les
éléments comme le blizzard qui gonflera
sa voile et l'aidera à tirer son fardeau
de 130 kg
c'est chez scott elle est un sacré
tempérament et ça je pense que c'est
très bien là bas tu as besoin d'un bon
tempérament pour te battre et des
batailles il y en aura beaucoup quand
elle sera fatigué que les journées
semblent trop longues ou bien qu'elle
prendra conscience qu'il y en a pour
deux mois à partir de la base qui elle
sera solide et son unique lien avec le
monde
une liaison satellite par semaine 10
heures de progression quotidienne 90
jours de quasi solitude dans son périple
elle n'aura droit qu'à une étape à
mi-parcours l'enfer blanc
laurence de la ferrière le connaît
pourtant elle est impatiente le corps
s'adapte c'est la tête
loewe art le corps sans la tête ferrer
un bon et donc il ya une période
d'adaptation qui a été dur mais qui
après très vite c'est s'est transformé
en une harmonie extraordinaire est
quelque chose de très exaltant et c'est
ce que je retiens de tout ça et c'est ce
que j'emmène avec moi cette fois c'est
pas je sais qu'il ya des moments qui
vont être difficiles mais je sais que je
vais pouvoir passer au delà
à 41 ans l'aventurière l'a compris
depuis longtemps
ce sont là les clés de cette terre
inconnue les clés pour accéder à ce
sentiment de plénitude rugby ça y est la
france ira bien en quarts dé finale à
dublin le quinze de france a battu les
fidji 28 à 19
il aura fallu attendre les dernières
minutes pour que les français signent
cette victoire christophe duchiron
frédérick basile comme emblème du quinze
de france cet après midi à toulouse on a
failli remplacer le coq par le couac
tout ça parce que les bleus devant leur
public ont failli connaître
l'humiliation de la défaite après 20
minutes de jeu 3 partout au score
benhadj a percuté tout en férocité
castagnède donne le ballon à christophe
juillet qui dégomme l'adversaire qui
s'écroule dans l'en but
essai transformé malheureusement
première période le bilan est maigre
trop de ballons perdus en touche et une
incapacité à prendre le jeu à son compte
c'est comme si le syndicat d'initiative
du quinze de france étaient fermés très
adroit repos seulement les vingt
premières minutes de la deuxième période
sont quasiment catastrophique les
filières qu'on croyait endormi se
réveille
lui nahio prend magnifiquement
l'intervalle et s'en va marquer entre
les poteaux
un peu plus tard little inscrit deux
pénalités et à la surprise générale
l'ific jamais 19 à 13
il ya le feu à la maison france mais le
mérite des français c'est d'avoir su
réagir au moment le plus critique
pendant six minutes il y à une
succession de mêlées à cinq mètres de la
ligne des pigeons tête contre tête les
bleus mettent tout leur corps et tout
leur coeur dans la pousser les blancs
qu'on s'en sortir dans d'autres
solutions que de commettre la faute
les bleus pour s'en sortir n'ont d'autre
solution que de marquer après sept
mêlées consécutives
larbi accorde un essai de pénalité et
désormais les français mais d'un petit
point vert à 19 en fin de rencontre les
bleus reviennent les bleus en marquant
un essai d'envergure
jusqu'à présent il y avait bien un match
de rugby
mais où était le spectacle cette fois
enfin ça commence mais dommage c'est
déjà fini
panique dans la défense des îles fidji
et pour conclure et c'est dodo m'initier
à la dernière minute
à défaut d'être brillants les bleus
vainqueurs 28 à 19 dans la douleur le
courage et la volonté dimanche prochains
jours un quart de finale à dublin
le départ de la transat le havre
carthagène en colombie une traversée de
l'atlantique en double à la voile sur la
ligne de départ cet après-midi sous le
soleil avec une mère parfaitement calme
les monocoques qui couvriront vie 1200
km parmi les équipages de heath parlier
qui fait figure de favori puisqu'il a
déjà remporté deux fois cette épreuve
cette fois ci il fait équipe avec une
jeune britannique de 23 ans qui a été la
révélation de la route du rhum en 98
c'est demain que les multicoques que
prendront la mer à leur tour d'eau mis à
l'honneur ce mois ci avec une double
exposition celle du grand palais bien
sûr mais aussi celle de l'isle adam ou
les organisateurs ont pris le parti de
s'intéresser à l'histoire de la
caricature en partant de l'oeuvre de
daumier jusqu'à nos jours avec un thème
essentiel celui de la justice
le mic verdeilhan et joseph belgique
accompagné du dessinateur du monde jean
plantu ont visité cette manifestation un
siècle les sépare mais c'est le même
regard que les deux hommes jettent sur
la justice il la juge satirique honoré
daumier dont les caricatures dans le
charivari visaient aussi bien
louis-philippe que les magistrats et les
avocats acide jean plantu qui
quotidiennement épingle les affaires et
leurs protagonistes à la une du monde me
plaît comme dessinateur d'aujourd'hui
c'est que on rentre dans l'intimité de
la personnalité de chacun c'est à dire
que on sent le côté cérébral du juge est
en sang le petit côté sa femme qui le
plein mais à la fois qui fait son boulot
de bon bah oui je sais tu as des
problèmes mais on peut imaginer qu'elle
a rien à secouer pour offense au roi
daumier condamné en 1832 à six mois de
prison
il est même qu'il était harcelé par les
autres des buts lui qui l'aurait qui lui
demandait le leur caricature
c'est incroyable qu'ils demandaient à
sortir de taule parce qu'il en avait
marre de trop travailler de saké d'année
autre dessinateur lui aussi condamné
pour ses dessins antimilitariste paru
dans l'assiette au beurre
jules grand joie c'est incroyable
c'est marrant parce qu'elle est nulle
y'a rien de vulgaire d'abord caricature
le dessin est devenu croquis d'audience
le procès de la sphère du canal de suez
en 1893 sous la plume de toulouse
lautrec landru croquer en 1921 barbie
par wiaz en 1996 regard divergences on
nous donnerons une bon dieu sans
confession trouver la touche juste y
ajouter le détail implacable furent
toujours le souci premier des
caricaturistes
mais chaque jour plantu lui se doit de
réagir vite
quand on me dit au journal on me dit
qu'à une demi heure pour faire un dessin
sur jupe est inculpé ou d'humains
inculpé c'est pas n'importe quoi parce
que même si je pense me dit j'ai pu
faire attention avant de toucher
pourquoi j'ai quand même une demi heure
pour jouer avec l'honneur de quelqu'un
il n'a souvent fallu qu'un coup de
crayon pour dénoncer une idée le temps a
fait le reste
alors le dessin est devenu le plus
implacable des réquisitoires contre la
justice
théâtre avec le parcours d'une des
jeunes vedettes montantes de la comédie
française
il s'appelle eric ruf il a tout juste 30
ans il saute de molière au théâtre
contemporain avec la même aisance
antoine cormery et joseph bachique ont
suivi les pérégrinations de ce comédien
qui rejettent les étiquettes
une gueule une vraie belle gueule de
comédien dans ce train qui l'emmène vers
l'orient eric ruf laisse derrière lui
les rôles de jeune premier dans
lesquelles la comédie française le
cantonnent encore il va rejoindre sa
troupe et son spectacle cette fois il ne
joue pas il dirige un an de travail avec
ses anciens élèves du cours florent pour
en arriver à ces belles endormies du
bord de seine et c'est important qu'ils
direction du visage qui change la met en
scène absolument c'est quoi une histoire
compliquée car dans cette pièce écrite
en commun avec les comédiens il n'est
question que de la mélancolie qui
parfois saisi les jeunes filles et les
conduit au suicide c'est gris et blanc
comme ici comme je suis heureuse comme
je suis heureuse enfin des tris y ait un
texte poétique mais difficile très loin
de molière dans les habits duquel avec
lui il va pourtant se glisser à nouveau
le soir même dans l'école des femmes
horace c'est lui sow reprend m'avez-vous
qui sont à prévoir levante ud ce faire
dieu je vais changer mon chose un essai
ça change un peu de l'ambiance de
lorient
oui et il dans le décor est dans le
texte et dans le décor là dans le texte
oui oui le texte a lorient on l'a écrit
donc je le sais un petit peu naturel
celui ci sont pas du tout fric élevé il
crie forcément donc on n'a pas joué
depuis quelques jours donc j'ai besoin
de me remettre en bouche il n ya encore
des allers retours comme celui là eric
ruf on a fait des dizaines dans l'année
c'est éreintant mais pour lui c'est un
moyen de ne pas se laisser enfermer dans
le confort douillet de la comédie
française
l'une des équipes de la rédaction de
france 2 a été récompensée aujourd'hui
le prix bayeux des correspondants de
guerre qui regroupe des journalistes du
monde entier a sélectionné le travail de
maryse burgot gilles jacquier fabien
brillant et martin johan est pour ce
reportage kosovo le chemin de l'exode
ils obtiennent le troisième prix je vous
propose un extrait de ce document que
nous avions diffusé en plein conflit du
kosovo
c'était en avril dernier
ils sont presque arrivés c'est adam et
wilm de marché pendant plus de trois
jours
nous avons entrepris de remonter ce long
chemin qui viennent d'emprunter eux à
rift au monténégro nous nous nous
dirigeons vers le kosovo
au début le chemin est assez praticable
puis c'est la moyenne montagne
les heures passent les colonnes d'hommes
de femmes et d'enfants
avant ce temps silence ou près
oh
à
on ne se plaint pas beaucoup chacun
c'est d'ici qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
choix que d'avancer
ils marchent parfois par petits groupes
chaque famille avancent ensemble car ils
n'ont abandonné personne
ceux qui ne peuvent pas marcher sont
aussi de cet incroyable voyage
et puis avant de refermer ce journal
saluant la sortie de notre confrère le
parisien qui sera dans les kiosques que
désormais tous les dimanches à partir
donc de demain
savin de cette édition je vous en
rappelle le principal titre
manifestation pour l'emploi paris à
l'initiative du parti communiste de
mobilisation au rendez vous plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes du
vert et du rouge dans les rues contre
les licenciements mais par contre le
gouvernement que c'est la météo avec
isabelle martinez 20h50 tapis rouge
présenté par michel drucker invités
muriel robin de master dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit le cascadeur
mario luraschi midi des m a présenté par
paul amar j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13h je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
fin de soirée sur france 2
autre